if a company is mining something they're
usually byproducts the stuff that's left
behind after extraction and processing
and these days the company should be
required to deal with those byproducts
but in the past they often just piled
them up and assumed that someone would
deal with the problem at some point in
the future if those byproducts are toxic
that's a problem but here in here show
in Germany it's a bit different just
over there is an open pit kale in mine
Kalin is a really common mineral that's
used in the manufacture of a lot of
things everything from Pottery to
toothpaste and there is a big pile of
mining byproduct here I'm standing on it
it is 120 meters high but it's just sand
regular sand made of quartz like what
you'd find in the desert quartz sand can
be useful in Industry these days the
sand that the mines produce here is sold
off but for decades there was too much
of it so as it was pretty harmless the
mining companies just piled it up what
do you do with 35 million tons of sand
in a pile that's dominating the
landscape the answer of course is making
a tourist attraction welcome to the ski
resort and amusement park of Mount
calino I should point out it's 9 A.M on
a weekday as I'm filming this so there
aren't many people around it's not fully
open in the summer school holidays this
place is as busy as a regular ski slope
would be in High season is
Alpine toaster
we have here adventure guys
a lot of this hill is covered in trees
and other vegetation and they will help
anchor the sand and keep everything in
place so I had to ask surely all the
people descending this mountain keep
dragging the sand down with themselves
I'm sure that the local government could
have insisted that this hill be cleaned
up in the sand disposed of somehow but
why would they now here shower isn't
just a mining town it's a mining town
with a local theme park tourists have a
reason to come here and spend money
there are more jobs for the locals and
every so often someone will come along
and tell the world that hey there is a
ski slope made of sand in Germany
I thought
I can't sandboard I would die this is
this is not the hill to learn on I'm
gonna I'm gonna take the little cable
car down how do I I'm genuinely
terrified I'm gonna slip off this how do
I get out of this that tightened it oh
my God okay